N
LAGUARDIA WITH THE TRAVEL
DELAYS, THANK YOU.
♪♪
YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE NOW AT
IMAGES FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
I OVER THE RIO GRANDE RIVER IN
EAGLE PASS THE SEVEN DAYS I WAS
THERE, MORE THAN 11000
ENCOUNTERS WITH MIGRANTS.
TODAY, THERE HAVE BEEN UPWARDS
OF 1700.
IT COMES AS THEY ARE TRYING TO
STRUGGLE WITH THE RECORD NUMBERS
CROSSING.
THIS IS GREG ABBOTT REACTING TO
THE SUPREME COURT GIVING THE
GREEN LIGHT TO ENTER THE TRUMP
ERA REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
ABBOTT WRITING, THE SUPREME
COURT DECISION HOLDING DHS
TERMINATION OF THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY WILL ONLY EMBOLDEN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN
BORDER POLICIES.
WE WERE ABLE TO SPEAK WITH THE
GOVERNOR DOWN ALONG THE RIVER
BANK HERE IS THE INTERVIEW.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW BAD THE
SITUATION IS RIGHT NOW IN YOUR
STATE.
>> LITERALLY IT'S NEVER BEEN
WORSE.
THE NUMBERS ARE HIGHER THAN THEY
HAVE EVER BEEN, PROBLEMS AND
CHALLENGES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER BUT WE ARE NOT SEEING
THE PRESIDENT TOUCHED A FINGER
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ABANDONED MANY OF
THE STATES, THE BORDER STATES OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WE SAW THE TRAGEDY THIS WEEK
IN SAN ANTONIO, WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION WHEN YOU FIRST LEARNED
ABOUT THAT?
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE NOW?
>> FIRST, THERE CAN'T BE
ANYTHING BUT SHOCK WHEN YOU HEAR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT IS A HORRIFIC TRAGEDY.
IT ALSO IS A BYPRODUCT BIDEN'S
BORDER POLICY.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A PRESIDENT
ENFORCING THE IMMIGRATION LAWS,
IT ATTRACTS THE CARTEL AND
SMUGGLERS TO DO WHAT THEY DID
THAT LED TO THIS DISASTER AND
THAT'S WHY WE CALL FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO STEP UP AND DO YOUR
JOB AND SECURE THE BORDER AND
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAWS.
>> YOU ARE TAKING ADDITIONAL
STEPS YOU WILL TAKE, TEXAS WILL
TAKE TO PREVENT TRAGEDIES LIKE
THE ONE WE SAW.
>> TO EXPLAIN THE CONTEXT, ONE
REASON IS THERE WAS INSUFFICIENT
BORDER PATROL, THIS VEHICLE
WHERE THEY HAVE PASSED AWAY WAS
NOT EXPECTED SO TEXAS IS DOING
IS DEPLOYING ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS TO CHECK THESE
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES TO DO OUR
PART TO PREVENT TRAGEDIES LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT REPUBLICANS,
HOW IMPORTANT YOU THINK THIS IS
AS WE HEAD INTO THE MIDTERMS?
>> IT IS A GAME CHANGER, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT LED TO THE
VICTORY FOR FLORIDA'S, NOT TOO
FAR FROM WHERE WE ARE NOW.
THIS TERRITORY ON THE BORDER WAS
DOMINATED BY DEMOCRAT AND NOW WE
HAVE THE FIRST MEXICAN BORN
HISPANIC WOMAN ELECTED AS A
REPUBLICAN TO THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY AND IT SHOWS THE
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE OF BORDER
SECURITY ISSUES THAT SHE
CAMPAIGNED ON.
>> AND OF COURSE A BORDER
COMMUNITY BUT VOTERS WELL NORTH
OF THE BORDER IN NORTHEAST
STATES AND BEYOND, SHOULD THEY
CARE?
>> THEY DO CARE AND ONE REASON,
FIRST OF ALL, THEY DON'T LIKE
SEEING THEIR BORDER OVERRUN, THE
LAWLESSNESS BUT ALSO, MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER ARE FLOWING INTO THEIR
STATES.
ON TOP OF THAT, PERHAPS WORSE,
FENTANYL IS MAKING IT THIS WAY
TO THEIR STATES ALSO.
COMMUNITIES IN NORTHERN U.S. AND
EASTERN AND WESTERN U.S. ARE
INFILTRATED WITH THIS DEADLY
FENTANYL.
THE BORDER CRISIS HAVING AN
EFFECT ON EVERY STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> DO YOU THINK WITH THE WAY THE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN SURGING, I
REMEMBER JUST LAST YEAR WE WOULD
HAVE A GROUP OF 100 BORDER
PATROLS, A LARGE GROUP.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE FIVE DAYS,
WE'VE HAD THREE OR 400 EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
CAN WE SUSTAIN THIS?
>> WITH THE AN ADEQUATE
PERSONNEL PROVIDED ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE, IT WILL BE MORE
DIFFICULT BUT THAT'S WHY I WAS
HERE TODAY, TO ANNOUNCE MORE
STRATEGIES OF WHAT TEXAS IS
DOING ABOUT PLAYING DOWN AND
BUILDING MORE BARRIERS AND
ADDING MORE TROOPS AND PERSONNEL
TO THE REASONS YOU SEE HIGH
INFLUX OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
TEXAS HAS PEOPLE TO HELP SOLVE
THE PROBLEM WHERE'S THE UNITED
STATES DOES NOT.
>> AS WE SIT HERE ALONG THE
BANKS OF THE RIO GRANDE, CARTEL
ARE WATCHING.
IS THIS CRISIS AND MINIMUM WAGE,
IS THIS SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER
SEEN?
>> THEY MAKE MONEY OFF EVERYBODY
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND
PEOPLE WHO LOSE THEIR LIVES IN
THAT TRUCK.
ONE OF OUR GOALS IS TO USE
STRATEGIES FOR THE CARTEL TO
LOSE MONEY IN TEXAS.
>> GOVERNOR, FINALLY, THIS IS A
OPEN ENDED QUESTION BUT HOW DOES
THIS AND?
>> IT ENDS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOING ITS JOB,
PROBABLY AND WITH A NEW
PRESIDENT.
IT COULD AND FAR QUICKER THAN
THAT BECAUSE REPUBLICANS, IN
JUST A FEW MONTHS, THEY CAN
BEGIN THE HEARINGS THAT MAY LEAD